I'm taking Boringa, the brand is Rosa Bella, to help us stress and sleep.
They are 800 milligram capsules.
The bottle cells don't take more than one a day.
I've not seen any differences yet after a week of taking them.
Would it be okay to take a higher dose?
Okay, so I looked at that brand and I would consider that an off brand.
Now, some of the off brand supplements can be just fine.
And some of the off brand supplements can be really bad.
So, how do you know?
Well, you don't.
I do know that there are certain brands that are very anal at testing their raw products.
And thereby, I have a lot of confidence in their final outcome.
So, that's one thing, especially with herbs.
So, that's what's more difficult to know.
So, if it's a mineral or a vitamin, it's easier to just look at the label.
For instance, if I'm looking at a mineral and it says calcium, as calcium carbonate,
you should just put that in your garden because nobody should consume that.
But if it said tracts or albium calcium and albaltracts or albium magnesium,
regardless if it was an off brand, they're using good minerals.
Go ahead and take that.
So, it's easier to look at a label and look at whether it's a synthetic bee.
That's not a good one to take.
If it's a soil-based mineral or something like that, that's a not good one to take.
But with herbs, it's more difficult because the labels can be very misleading.
It can have very beautiful, colorful label because they did a wonderful job marketing.
But there can be almost none of the product in there.
And this was tested about auditing.
So, if you're looking at the label, you can see that it's not a good one to take.
And this was tested about, I don't know, maybe eight years ago, independent lab,
ran tests on different herbs.
I've talked about this before and they found that some of them literally had none in the capsule,
none of the herb that it was talked about in the capsule.
So, that's where you have to be careful with the brand that you're using.
So, I can't vouch for this Roosevelt brand.
But let's say they are 800 milligrams in those capsules, or let's say it's 800 milligrams in two capsules
and they're recommending two capsules a day.
And it says don't take more than that because they're just trying to,
lots of times they'll say don't take more than that.
If they're just trying to protect themselves, they want you to talk to somebody.
They're not a, they're not your physician, right?
So, they want you to, you know, definitely nobody's ever going to get hurt
with taking it 100 milligrams of moringa.
However, there's good reputable brands that I would say that have more than that in it,
and recommend three times that dose even on their label.
So, there really isn't a dangerous dose of moringa.
I would say like any herb, moringa is one that could be tainted, could be dirty.
A lot of the herbs have, a lot of heavy metals and toxins in them, pesticides and herbicides.
So, by, you want to try to stay to organic herbs, I don't know that brand.
But in general, if it was a good, clean organic brand, no, you could take more.